bonjour et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition dans le cadre d'europe
dans cette émission je vous emmène en
grande bretagne un pays où malgré
l'euroscepticisme ambiant le programme
erasmus attire de plus en plus
d'étudiants direction ensuite la
roumanie un pays qui se vide de ses
médecins parti à l'ouest de l'europe
chercher de meilleures conditions de
travail et de meilleurs salaires
enfin terminus au portugal un pays rongé
par l'illettrisme là-bas en pleine crise
économique
associations et gouvernement prennent le
problème à bras le corps mais d'abord
flora sauvage nous emmène en belgique un
pays qui a légalisé le mariage
homosexuel en 2003 sans susciter
particulièrement de débats flora la
belgique après les pays bas et le
deuxième pays d'europe à avoir adopté le
mariage homosexuel comment est ce que
s'est passé le débat sur place en fait
le débat s'est passé dans un contexte
plutôt apaisé contrairement à ce qu'on a
pu voir en france la raison principale à
mon avis est que le gouvernement belge a
choisi de séparer la question du mariage
pour les couples de même sexe et la
question de l'adoption
si bien que finalement la loi sur le
mariage est passée un peu comme une
lettre à la poste
en 2003 et trois ans plus tard le
gouvernement est revenu à la charge
cette fois avec les questions de
l'adoption et l'adoption a été votée en
2006 en belgique
donc là on vous suit à bruxelles à la
rencontre de haan et vert
en couple depuis neuf ans à nevers l'ont
choisi de se marier dans quelques mois
elles vont se dire oui devant leur
famille et leurs amis comme n'importe
quel couple depuis 2003 en belgique
le mariage est ouvert à tous y compris
aux personnes de même sexe on n'a plus
revu
quand on a des enfants on voulait des
enfants on va se marier c'est aussi pour
dire aux gens aux amis là pour l'autre
derrière ce mariage d'amour c'est aussi
un moyen de protéger leurs enfants
si l'une ou l'autre des ced pour elle le
mariage est un droit fondamental auquel
tous les citoyens doivent avoir accès qu
aimer quelqu'un ça n'a rien à voir avec
le sexe et si c'est un homme ou une
femme
il faut être vraiment ouvert et dire
c'est la même chose c'est vraiment la
même chose tu veux que tout le monde à
la fois pour sa verve et la maman
biologique des deux enfants 6 qui a
trois ans et y est sa petite soeur sont
issus d'un don de sperme
ici en belgique depuis une trentaine
d'années la procréation médicalement
assistée est accessible à toutes les
femmes y compris aux lesbiennes
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être stérile
pour y avoir accès j'étais un sommet
avec 2 min de lui-même
grâce à la loi sur l'adoption votée en
2006 anna pu adopter les enfants et
devenir leur mère au même titre que sa
compagne le loi de l'adoption
et même plus plus important pour nous
pour que la loire de la mariage parce
que quand il arrive quelque chose avec
moi qu'il va se coupler la maison fronte
en belgique dix ans après le vote de la
loi
le mariage homosexuel est entré dans les
moeurs un millier de mariage de même
sexe sont célébrés chaque année ce qui
représente 2 % des unions civiles
en 2003 le sujet n'a quasiment pas fait
débat
plus que le mariage c'est la question de
la filiation et de l'adoption qui ont
suscité des résistances
karine lalieux est députée fédérale
socialiste elle a voté en faveur de la
loi sur le mariage gay les socialistes
et la majorité des partis flamands sauve
les partis flamands catholique était
pour directement ouvrir aussi à
l'adoption
mais il ya eu un veto du parti libéral
en disant si adoption il y aura pas de
mariage alors qu'on avait une majorité
pour faire adopter son démarchage en
même temps nous avons cédé nous avons
fait uniquement le mariage qui était
déjà un premier pas face aux réticences
le choix a été fait de séparer la
question du mariage et celle de
l'adoption au siège de cette association
de défense des droits des homosexuels
on salue l'action des politiques c'était
une volonté stratégique aussi du pouvoir
politique à l'époque de ne pas faire
passer les deux loin en même temps tant
qu'ils ont attendu quelques années et en
2006 ils ont fait passer la loi sur
l'adoption qui étaient intégrés quelque
part aussi à une révision de la loi qui
existait déjà puisqu'ils ont revu
l'adoption intrafamiliales et de dombes
et ils ont rajouté que les couples homos
avait aussi
droit à l'adoption et malgré les
réticences de certains le débat en
belgique s'est passé dans un climat
apaisé sans aucune manifestation
désormais plus personne ne remette en
cause le mariage ou l'adoption par les
homosexuels
je crois qu'il est important à un moment
donné que le politique en matière
éthique précède la société assume des
choix assume d inventer sociétal même si
l opposition à la société parce qu'on
voit après que si il ya une
normalisation est menaçable ça calme
toutes les passions la belgique est
devenue le deuxième pays au monde après
les pays bas à légaliser le mariage et
l'adoption pour les personnes de même
sexe l'espagne la suède ou le portugal
ont suivi en europe aujourd'hui sept
pays autorise le mariage homosexuel
flora dix ans après son adoption quel
bilan peut-on tirer aujourd'hui de du
mariage gay en belgique
alors c'est un bilan plutôt positif en
ce qui concerne le mariage puisque les
statistiques montrent qu' environ un
millier de mariage gay para en belgique
donc milan plutôt positif
après en ce qui concerne l'adoption par
les couples de même sexe là c'est un
bilan beaucoup plus mitigé puisqu'on
s'est rendu compte que dans les faits la
loi sur l'adoption par les couples de
même sexe est plutôt d'ordre symbolique
puisqu'il n'y a eu aucune adoption
internationale par des couples
homosexuels belge 2006 si aucune
adoption internationale exemple la chine
qu'il a clairement spécifié elle ne
souhaite pas que ses enfants soient
adoptés par des couples de même sexe et
florent comment est ce que nos voisins
belges ont perçu le débat que nous avons
eu en france sur la question du mariage
pour tous c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est que en belgique
certains étaient absolument persuadé que
le mariage homosexuel existaient déjà et
est déjà légale en france
et puis la plupart de mes interlocuteurs
m'ont dit qu'ils étaient assez étonné
certains parfois choqué par les propos
d'une extrême violence qui ont pu être
tenus ici et puis et puis souvent très
étonné par le monde qui a pu descendre
dans la rue
puisque comme je vous l'expliquais en
belgique il n'y a pas eu ces grandes
manifestations qu'on a pu voir en france
et ses grands débats que qu'ils ont pu
avoir lieu ici
merci flora merci à vous on dit l'europe
en crise crise financière crise
économique crise de confiance pourtant
s'il ya bien un programme qui résiste
aux soubresauts de l'union européenne
après 25 ans d'existence c'est bien
erasmus
alors paul bouffard a été à la rencontre
de ces jeunes qui tentent l'expatriation
direction l'angleterre paul que
symbolise erasmus et bien qui ne connaît
pas le fameux film de cédric klapisch
l'auberge espagnole
tous les jeunes et moins jeunes
d'ailleurs on rêver devant les scènes
étudiante erasmus c'est un programme qui
a maintenant 25 ans il permet aux
étudiants de l'union européenne de vivre
à l'étranger pendant six mois d'étudier
à l'étranger
et puis et c'est l'âme du projet c
permet l'intégration culturelle
européenne
combien de personnes ont bénéficié de ce
programme erasmus depuis sa création en
87 en 1987 c'est plus de 3 millions de
jeunes qui ont bénéficié du programme et
quels sont les pays les plus concernés
et bien c'est l'espagne qui arrive en
tête avec 40 mille étudiants l'année
dernière mais vous vous êtes rendu donc
à londres dans un pays qui est plutôt
eurosceptiques
on a voulu voir si le programme était
toujours attractif
au milieu des flocons de neige tanguy 23
ans loin de sa région lyonnaise
le frenchy s'est lancé dans des études à
l'étranger en marketing international
ici sur le campus de l'université
anglaise de reading à quelques minutes
de londres
donc aujourd'hui travailler et découvrir
ce que c'est que la vie erasmus
ça apporte beaucoup de choses notamment
une première expérience à
l'international
ça permet aussi découvrir de nouvelles
cultures de s'adapter à un nouveau et un
nouvel environnement
et puis ça permet aussi une certaine
ouverture d'esprit qui est un prérequis
actuellement dans le monde du travail de
soissons une expérience internationale
est forcément un avantage sur lci
erasmus
une succès story d'un quart de siècle le
programme d'échangé ducati a fait ses
preuves
il permet aux étudiants européens de
faire une partie de leur cursus
universitaire à l'étranger
près de 3 millions de jeunes en ont
bénéficié
un système qui a fait de la mobilité
étudiante le trait d'union entre pays de
l'union européenne en 1987
l'objectif était dé veiller l'identité
citoyenne du vieux continent et paroles
de professeurs ça marche encore depuis
quinze ans françoise le saut enseigne à
l'université de reading
l'intérêt est toujours aussi vivace et
du point de vue d'une enseignante dans
une section de langues modernes
je dirais même que le programme erasmus
et est devenue absolument essentielles
sont des étudiants qui vont être assidu
ce sont des étudiants qui vont être
enthousiaste qui vont s'exprimer
beaucoup aux classes dans les
discussions et dans les débats et qui
vont apporter un point de vue légèrement
différent qui est aussi extrêmement
enrichissant pour les étudiants locaux
pourtant ces dernières semaines à court
d'argent
l'union européenne a voulu couper dans
le budget du programme
victimes collatérales de la crise eh
bien non les instances européennes
reviennent sur la décision et propose
même d'augmenter de 70 % le budget sur
la période 2014 à 2020 je crois que les
fonctionnaires
de bruxelles n'ont strictement aucune
crainte à avoir
c'est un système qui qui a de beaux
jours devant lui
simplement parce que c'est un système
qui s'est rendu absolument indispensable
tu cherches
le royaume uni une terre ou neuro
scepticisme n'est plus légende
et pourtant ici le programme est en
pleine progression
même si les chiffres ne sont pas ceux de
l'espagne ou de la france au british
council organisation gouvernementale
pour l'éducation
on est loin d'abandonner erasmus
on est très content de voir une
augmentation du nombre d'étudiants ces
sept dernières années depuis que le
british council finances ce programme on
a noté une hausse de 8% par an du nombre
d'étudiants pour l'année passée nous
avons eu plus de 13000 généra smith
c'est un record pour le 25e anniversaire
du programme
preuve que ça marche bien et les primes
en tout cas clairement s'ils veulent
travailler dans un autre pays européen
c'est un plus pour eux car ils ont une
ouverture d'esprit
mais même s'il reste ici au royaume uni
les employeurs disent que ces étudiants
sont plus matures ils ont plus de choses
à offrir qu'un étudiant qui est resté
chez lui salut de mieux la maison
moi je sois jeu
à reading tanguy vit en colocation avec
d'autres étudiants étrangers m pour eux
cette réussite coûte cher être étudiant
erasmus n'est aujourd'hui plus donné à
tout le monde
certains parlent même d'un système
réservé à des étudiants favorisés alors
pour être étudiant asmus il faut avoir
quelques quelques sous de côté parce que
la bourse erasmus ne suffit pas bien sûr
ce que ce que ce que les bourses ne
finance pas c'est mes parents qui
finance alors moi le montant mamour
cisse élèves à 1500 euros à peu près
pour les neuf mois où j'étudie en
erasmus bora étudiant espagnol de 25 ans
voit dans ce programme une solution pour
trouver du travail en espagne
un jeune sur deux est au chômage alors
lui il pense rester en angleterre en
espagne aujourd'hui c'est pratiquement
impossible de trouver un travail solo en
angleterre ça me semble plus facile
j'aurai plus de possibilités ici prime
locaux premièrement mon anglais s'est
améliorée vraiment et ensuite avoir un
diplôme validé à l'étranger c'est plus
valorisant que dans son propre pays
m
alors erasmus une solution à la crise
une chose est sûre le programme est
inscrit au patrimoine européen en 2011
deux cent trente mille étudiants ont
bénéficié d'erasmus désormais chaque
année l'objectif sera de permettre à ces
deux cent mille nouveaux jeunes
d'étudier à l'étranger mais pas le
malgré son succès on voit bien que
erasmus a été menacée de coupes
budgétaires que s'est il passé
l'europe est en crise l'austérité
budgétaire plane sur le vieux continent
et fin 2012
erasmus était menacée il manquait 90
millions pour boucler le budget l'union
européenne du coup voulait faire des
coupes dans son portefeuille pour faire
des économies mais la réalité c'est
qu'erasmus ne coûte pas si cher que ça
c'est 470 millions d'euros en moyenne
pour une année d'études
ce n'est rien par rapport aux 55
milliards de la politique agricole
commune est maintenant finalement est-ce
que ce programme est sauvé aujourd'hui
erasmus est plus ou moins sauvé en
décembre le parlement a soutenu la corde
6 milliards d'euros destinée à couvrir
les dépenses en cours et le budget 2013
est ce que ça pourrait être un facteur
des migrations pour ces jeunes on l'a vu
dans le reportage avec le jeune bora le
jeune espagnol qui fait son erasmus en
angleterre lui il a une idée en tête
c'est resté sur place pour trouver du
travail
il explique en espagne s'il était resté
en espagne il sera au chômage
effectivement un jeune espagnol sur deux
55% des moins de 25 ans sont aujourd'hui
est sans emploi
merci paul si les étudiants peuvent
librement circuler en europe c'est aussi
le cas des travailleurs
attirés par les rémunérations les
médecins roumains vont de plus en plus
émigré en france ou en belgique et iasi
deuxième vie de roumanie devient peu à
peu un désert médical marie vraiment
aussi rendu
marie le problème des déserts médicaux
est connue dans toute l'europe quelle
est la particularité de la roumanie
c'est vrai que la roumanie est un cas à
part quelques chiffres ils sont parlants
en roumanie à peu près deux médecins
pour 1000 habitants quand dans le reste
de l'europe
il y a quatre médecins environ pour 1000
habitants c'est donc très peu le budget
dévolu à la santé en roumanie est
également très faible c'est dû à la
situation économique du pays mais c'est
également les résultats de choix
politiques
la part budgétaire donc consacré à la
santé correspond à 4% du produit
intérieur brut roumains alors que dans
le reste de l'europe les dépenses
médicales représente environ 8% du pib
et c'est une moyenne car dans certains
pays d'europe de l'ouest de l' ocde
c'est plutôt 10 à 12% du pib' elle les
écarts sont donc très important donc
vous vous êtes rendus à iasi ont reçu
cette excuse non vous accompagnez
monsieur il a un problème
je veux qu'il aille en sénologie cela
fait 13 ans que christian paire ianu et
médecin urgentiste
il exerce dans le plus important hôpital
public de iasi deuxième ville de
roumanie l'hôpital saint spiridon
tourner tant bien que mal il faudrait 25
% de médecins en plus pour sortir du
sous effectif chronique les moules de
l'oqlf il il ya beaucoup de boulot
c'est difficile de dire combien d'heures
on travaille par jour car on travaille
beaucoup aussi sur notre temps libre
pour gagner un peu plus avec son travail
l'enseignement et des extras christian
arrive à gagner 1000 euros par mois un
salaire peu élevé pour un métier
difficile qui requiert dix ans d'études
il lui arrive d'envisager de partir en
belgique ou ailleurs
son profil est très recherché
récemment j'ai reçu des offres de la
part de plusieurs agences de recrutement
des agences de recrutement qui sont très
agressives elles recherchent du
personnel qualifié pour travailler à
l'ouest de l'europe à l'ouest de
l'europe des déserts médicaux en
roumanie
le malaise de médecins qui se sentent
bien souvent dénigré et souffre d'un
manque de reconnaissance
ici les politiques de santé ne
représentent que 4% du produit intérieur
brut contre 10% en moyenne en europe
isabelle à 30 ans et dans quelques mois
alors achevé son internat sa spécialité
anesthésie en soin intensif elle
l'exercera sans doute pour un temps tout
du moins ailleurs on pêche ce serait
l'occasion d'une nouvelle expérience
dans un hôpital où il y a une bonne
organisation et des moyens conséquents
et bien sûr il y à l'argent tout le
monde sait qu'on est mieux payé à
l'étranger qu'en roumanie je choisirais
bien la france car je parle la langue
et puis j'ai beaucoup de collègues qui
sont déjà et qui ont des expériences
réussies là bas
la france et la belgique des
destinations privilégiées
les roumains sont francophones depuis
l'adhésion du pays à l'union européenne
en 2007
l'équivalence des diplômes et la libre
circulation le phénomène est alarmant en
cinq ans 14 mille médecins ou quitter la
roumanie alors que sur la même période
seuls douze mille achever leur internat
en roumanie il ya un peu moins de deux
médecins pour 1000 habitants quand la
moyenne en europe et de 3,7
l'ordre des médecins roumains assiste
impuissant à une hémorragie qui dure et
s'accentue
si ce genre d'exode continue dans
quelques années le système de santé
roumain va péricliter
steen situation très grave mais
malheureusement les hommes politiques
roumains ne comprennent pas cela et
n'ont pris aucune mesure pour les
inciter à rester dans notre système de
santé mais léger insisté amendé
sanatatea longuenesse
à la faculté de médecine de iasi l'heure
est aux examens pour ces étudiants en
première année d'un à deux sets ça je
vous prie d'aller là bas pas encore
doctor est pourtant un quart d'entre eux
a déjà le regard tourné vers l'ouest qui
pense parmi vous qu'il travaillera à
l'étranger lever la main ceux pour qui
c'est le cas depuis 2007 cette fuite des
médecins auraient déjà coûté l état
roumain 3 milliards d'euros une grande
partie de la formation est prise en
charge par les pouvoirs publics alors
des voix s'élèvent pour demander aux
pays qui attire et profite de ses
médecins de mettre la main à la poche
une sorte de juste retour sur
investissement pour la roumanie
marie on voit clairement dans votre
reportage qu'il existe de grandes
disparités entre l'europe de l'est et
l'europe de l'ouest est ce qu'il ya un
manque de coordination au niveau
européen des politiques de santé
c'est vrai qu'on assiste à des
situations complètement ubuesque où les
médecins roumains viennent travailler en
france parce que les salaires ils sont
bien plus élevés on dit aujourd'hui
qu'il y aurait quatre mille sept cents
médecins roumains en france donc c'est
quand même conséquent de l'autre côté il
y à des étudiants français en médecine
qui vont poursuivre leurs études en
roumanie à cause du numerus clausus en
france ces quotas d'étudiants admis en
deuxième année à iasi rouge était par
exemple il y avait il ya cette année 700
étudiants français qui étudie la
médecine ayache mais au delà on se rend
compte qu'il ya aussi un véritable
business autour de ces questions de
santé à bucarest ces dernières années ce
sont les agences de recrutement qui ont
fleuri ces agences qui sont chargés par
les directeurs d'hôpitaux étrangers de
recruter les spécialistes qui manque les
médecins qui manque et c'est vrai
qu'elles sont très agressifs très actifs
qu'elles proposent les offres très
alléchantes
autre signe que c'est devenu un business
deux fois par an roumanie il ya une fois
aux médecins en décembre 2012 dont
décembre dernier des représentants du
conseil général de la sarthe et taillage
où j'étais et se sont rendus à la
faculté de médecine pour se faire
connaître mais sans doute aussi pour
repérer d'éventuels futurs médecins
merci marie l'illettrisme plus que
jamais un handicap et un stigmate alors
en temps de crise économique ne pas
maîtriser la lecture et l'écriture peut
se révéler un frein indépassable pour
espérer retrouver un emploi en europe 75
millions de personnes sont concernées et
le portugal est l'un des plus mauvais
élèves
sandra cerqueira a mené l enquête
ce qui est étonnant son bras c'est que
finalement on pourrait se dire qu en
europe l'illettrisme et éradiquer et ce
n'est pas le cas non sont concernés par
l'illettrisme les personnes qui n'ont
pas acquis le socle commun de
connaissance minimum tel que l'écriture
le calcul ou la lecture
alors il est vrai que c'est un phénomène
qui existe depuis toujours dans les pays
du sud notamment la grèce le portugal
l'espagne ou l'italie et c'est un
phénomène assez tabou voire cacher il a
fallu attendre fin 2012 pour que l'union
européenne se saisisse du sujet et
alerte même sur ce sujet en rédigeant un
rapport pour dire que ce phénomène de
l'illettrisme concerne 75 millions de
personnes en europe soit un européen sur
sept et le portugal est le plus mauvais
élève de l'europe
oui c'est là où on trouve les plus
mauvais chiffres là aux 30% des jeunes
quittent l'école en ayant des
difficultés à lire et à écrire
là aussi où 72 % des actifs n'ont pas
fréquenté le secondaire donc forcément
en temps de crise ce sont ces personnes
là qui ont le plus de mal à trouver un
emploi
d'autant que le l'illettrisme favorise
aussi l'exclusion et la pauvreté
c'est le cas du portugal et c'est là la
difficulté alors là on vous suit dans la
banlieue de porto
écrire un geste familier que certains
dans l'enfance n'ont jamais vraiment
apprivoiser nous sommes dans ce qu'on
appelle au portugal un centre des
nouvelles opportunités créé avec le
soutien du fonds social européen des
cours du soir pour remettre à niveau
ceux qui ont quitté l'école trop tôt la
plupart dans cette classe ils sont
restés moins de 6 ans certaines morts
j'ai grandi dans une famille de sept
enfants
les frères ne sont allés à l'école
primaire et nous père m'a dit que même
si j'étais le plus jeune je ne pouvais
pas étudié plus que thomas il faut plus
qu'un hommage
ils ont entre 40 et 50 ans et
réapprennent aujourd'hui ce qui nous
semble à tous être des acquis au
portugal 72 % des actifs n'ont pas
fréquenté le secondaire
j'ai arrêté l'école à 12 ans il y avait
un trop grand fossé entre moi et les
jeunes générations y compris avec mes
filles c'était dépassé par les
connaissances actuelles et j'ai ressenti
le besoin de reprendre les études
intel moustache poussins certains
rencontrent des difficultés au début
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les connaissances
de base suffisante
ils ont perdu l'habitude d'écrire et de
lire la moitié de la population active
du pays a quitté l'école à 14 15 ans en
trois ans la fréquentation du centre a
doublé louise vient d'arriver pour
constituer un dossier et suivre des
cours il a commencé à travailler à 14
ans dans la vente aujourd'hui au chômage
il ne pensait pas qu'un jour le manque
d'études serait un handicap
hu il y a deux ans j'ai perdu un emploi
parce que je n'étais même pas aller au
collège
ces adultes qui arrivent ici ont tous
entre 40 50 ans ils ont travaillé dans
la même entreprise depuis qu'ils sont
tout jeunes et quand ils se retrouvent
au chômage
ils ont de l'expérience certes mais le
manque de qualification l'aurait
vraiment fatale
d'emblée ils sont exclus du marché du
travail
le portugal mauvais élèves de l'europe
mais dans le reste de l'union aussi lire
et écrire sans peine n'est pas une
évidence un tiers de la population
active est peu ou pas qualifiés et
concernant les plus jeunes générations
les chiffres ne sont guère meilleures
20% des jeunes sortent de l'école sans
avoir acquis le niveau de compétence
minimum le portugal connaît là encore le
taux le plus élevé d'europe 30%
d'abandon scolaire chez les jeunes dans
cette école de la deuxième chance
la seule du pays les élèves n'ont pas
étudié plus que leurs parents quand ils
arrivent ici ils ont arrêté les cours
depuis de nombreuses années chaque jour
pour l'eau participe aux cours de
cuisine pour réapprendre à travailler en
groupe ils préparent ensemble le
déjeuner pour toute l'école
il a 23 ans et n'est même pas allé au
collège c'est pour travailler et aider
sa famille qu'il a décidé d'arrêter les
études l'école envoyé des lettres à mes
parents pour dire j'y allais plus mais
ça n'a servi à rien depuis j'ai cherché
du travail je n'ai rien trouvé
je pensais que d'arrêter l'école à 15
ans n'empêcherait pas de travailler dans
la restauration
souvent les jeunes portugais décroche
faute d'encadrement familial
c'est l'héritage de la dictature
salazariste qui négligea pendant 40 ans
l'éducation des masses ici on est plus
que des formateurs
on remplace la famille les parents
quitté licol six jeunes favorise
l'exclusion sociale on leur apprend à
retrouver un cadre c'est important pour
eux pour la suite
faute de moyens l'école a failli fermer
l'an passé le directeur se dit inquiet
car les demandes d'inscription ne cesse
d'augmenter
le portugal est dans une situation
économique très difficile on est de
toute façon on ne peut pas se passer de
cette jeune génération parce que nous
avons l'une des populations les plus
vieillissante d'oran incontestablement
l'illettrisme est une entrave à la
croissance
un vrai handicap pour la compétitivité
le pays doit faire les efforts
nécessaires pour que les qualifications
augmente nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
d'autant que le pays possède également
le taux de scolarisation dans le
supérieur le plus faible de l'union
européenne pourtant dans dix ans
seulement 15% des emplois seront
destinés aux basses qualification sandra
ce qui semble assez étonnant c'est que
la situation du portugal s'était
améliorée lors de son entrée dans la
communauté économique européenne et
finalement avec la crise le problème de
l'illettrisme ressurgit pourquoi lors de
son entrée au sein de la communauté
européenne en 86 le portugal a reçu
énormément dead pour combler son retard
en matière d'éducation il faut dire que
le pays venait de loin dans les années
60 il y avait une personne sur deux qui
ne savaient ni lire ni écrire donc oui
il ya une amélioration le chemin
parcouru est énorme mais c'est vrai
qu'avec la crise on voit énormément de
jeunes qui décrochent qui quittent
l'école très tôt comme leurs parents il
ya la moitié des jeunes qui aujourd'hui
n'étudie pas plus que leurs parents et
en temps de crise économique ça
n'arrange rien non parce que le pays est
dans une logique de restriction
budgétaire de coupes budgétaires à tout
va et l'éducation est directement touché
et c'est vrai que sans son diplôme et le
pays ne pourra pas faire la croissance
du pays ne pourra pas repartir
vous le disiez son bras il faut pour
espérer une reprise économique une
population qui est qualifié or un tiers
de la population européenne et peu
qualifiés est de plus en plus d'emploi
ne trouvent pas preneur pour quelles
raisons
oui si on prend le secteur de
l'informatique et du numérique par
exemple des centaines d'emplois sont
créés chaque année et pourtant il n'y a
pas de diplôme est suffisant pour
satisfaire la demande ce qui peut
paraître contradictoire à l'heure où les
taux de chômage en europe flambent mais
en fait ça montre un peu le contraste
qui s'accentue entre une économie du
tertiaire qui nécessite beaucoup de
diplômés et une population européenne
qui décrochent côté qualification et
pourtant d'ici dix ans seuls 15% des
emplois seront destinés aux basses
qualification moralité la situation
n'est pas prête de s'arranger
merci sandra merci nora voilà c'est la
fin de cette émission nous on se
retrouve très vite sur public sénat et
tous les jours sur publicsenat.fr
à bientôt